I want you to I want everybody in my chat to go talk to their
normie friends and their normie co-workers that don't consume
political coverage every day. And I want you to ask them how
would you feel if Barack Obama said I am not going to disavow
until Donald Trump disavows and just listen to what they tell
you. >> Unsubscribing Hutch you're
>> good good riddens.
>> This was this was like all day. This is this is hours
ago. But he made one comment about how like we should probably
disavow violence and it was all day. people just being like,
"You understand that they they will they're going to get violent.
You understand that they're the worst, right? You understand."
It's like, >> I would encourage you guys to go touch grass,
talk to people, and ask them how they would react. >> Touch
touch baby. >> When people come and tell you like how normal
people take things, and you're like, "Wait, like who?" And they're
like, "Oh, I don't know any." That's it's a rough moment. Okay.
I can follow Kanye. I can't follow food shops. I can actually
piece together what Kanye is saying. I can't follow food shops
at all. I need you need conservatives to be afraid of getting
killed when they go to events so that they look to their leadership
to turn down the temperature. The issue is right now they don't
feel like there's any fear like I don't know. I don't know. It's
like memes. It's just memes to everybody I guess. I don't know,
bro. I don't know. I don't care. God, I'm It's going to be so
gay if I get killed the next two months of I'm doing all the
out here. Please don't anybody make any actual the most weak
ass speeches on my side. God, if it happens. Holy [__]
I'm going to make a death note before I go out to go live and
not God. It's so
It's so optics.
We're back. We're back. There it is. There it is. No fooling
around with the subreddit today. No fooling around. Just right
into content, guys. Okay. If every elected politician, if every
elected Democrat across the country right now took Destiny's
position of refusing to disavow, we will not win control of the
House, we will lose. I promise you. And if you're saying that
that's the better outcome for whatever reason, you can try to
articulate that. And at the end of the day, it all that just
comes down to accelerationism.
If maybe you could find a way to convince me that accelerationism
is the right strategy right now. Maybe. I guess. I don't know.
I'm open to anything, I guess. But you're going to have a hard
time convincing me.
>> That was a reciprocal disavow. >> What? What?
What's up? >> The way the way that he just said that right
there. Okay,
my mind is still fried from being in this online cult. But if
that's how you say no to this guy would get robbed.
>> You could convince me. No, I don't really want to do
that. But I mean, you could convince me. I guess I could be >> Maybe.
But probably. No, you probably couldn't convince me. But maybe.
>> But maybe >> though I don't even >> Oh,
I do owe you guys an hour, don't I? Hold on. Switch it over to
5 hours. There it is. I do owe you guys an hour. >> You
guys are I'm wrong. You Okay, let's say, you know, let's say
that there's a Let's just Let's just imagine. Okay,
we all agree about that.
>> Let's just imagine. I don't even know where it goes
from there. I got sent a few more clips of stuff going on earlier
today. Let's see.
I was paranoid on my walk, you know, I just had some personal
>> talking about this him talking about the doxing stuff
>> revealed. And so, uh, in the last like month and, uh,
I, you know, Los Angeles is big, right? There's like 10 million
people in the Los Angeles County. I I keep getting that number
right. Hold on. Or wrong. Los Angeles County, I think, is like
around 12 million. That's 9.5
>> You know, I was on my walk and some guy walked past
me. He had a backpack and uh >> was he blooked behind me
and I never do >> I don't don't know why that's why >> it
got so much it got so much better because you asked and then
he's like I look behind me. I never do that. Awesome >> I
never do that. I feel really safe in Los Angeles when I take
my walks, you know, my afternoon constitutionals. And it was
the day that I saw his murder, the brutal murder on the same
day, you know, this guy walks past me with a backpack and I Wow.
Wow.
A guy with a backpack hutch. That's crazy. Tell me more.
Okay, hold on. Hold on. Okay, so basically it's this whole stream.
I have not gone through this stream. I just got like clips occasionally
from the stream. All right, so I don't know the exact layout
of the stream. We can go to the start of the food shops call.
I I'm guessing that it's going to be No, Destiny doesn't actually
advocate for violence, but if you let Republicans do whatever,
it's like anybody who does the universal or the uh what do you
call it? The the dis the uh oh, is it unilateral disarmament,
right? Anybody does that meme. It's like, okay, but you have
to understand that you're not you're not saying, well, we're
not going to develop the technology or we can't do this later.
You're saying like this is not this is not mutually assured destruction.
It's like somebody just shot someone. You can disavow that. That's
not like having the weapon. That's like using the weapon. That's
like you're somebody just shot a nuke at the other side and you're
not like, "Yeah, I don't really want to shoot nukes." You're
like, "No, you need to disavow shooting nukes, too, at the same
time." It's like, bro, they just got hit with a nuke. Like, can
we chill? Can we chill? Can we chill the out? I was paranoid
on my walk. >> Oh, whoops. Okay, so I'll keep I'll keep
going through a couple of these. Apparently, somebody called
in to correct him about stuff. >> I think you're doing
I'm going to take a step back. You're not doing anybody like
a good thing, bro. I don't care. I'm going hard. >> You're
doing everybody a disservice by going like, "You know what, Charlie
Kirk? You know, at least he leaned left in the end." If you're
saying like that, >> when did I say that? >> I'm
not. >> Oh, I I remember I watched this clip earlier. Okay.
All right. I I hate to say it. That is a funny joke. I've I haven't
heard that one. I didn't see the one on Twitter. >> Say
you said that. I'm not saying >> Why are you bringing it
up? >> I'm I'm not debating you. I'm giving an example
of what the left is doing that they shouldn't be doing. >> Those
people who are saying that aren't leftists. Those are communists
and crazy people. We don't we don't claim those. >> I I
don't I disagree. I I think that the communist and socialists
are on the left even no matter how badly you don't want them
to be. >> We don't claim them. Nope. >> Okay. You
might not. You might not me a politician that claims them.
What What branch is Hassan in in our government? I for I'm confused.
>> I'm sorry. You me you meant politician as somebody who's
in the government like Yes. Yes. Name me one who's my mean. >> Can
you define that? Can you define that word for me? What is a what
is a politician exactly? So I I'm just going through a couple
of these clips cuz we'll we'll jump to wherever the food shop
food shop's time stamp is cuz that's where the actual sweeping
is going to happen, I would imagine. So
>> wait, there's one more. >> I'm so
Uh, yeah, it is [__] up. Yeah. >> No, don't
say it's [__] up. You're the person who made me see
it in a supermarket. I didn't This [__] >> I
didn't know what it was. >> Hold on. Hold on. >> Well,
look at this. >> And I I almost started crying in the chips
aisle. Like,
>> I didn't even know what the [__] you were
showing me. >> I don't think I told that whole story on
stream. I think I left out the part that I showed you. We're
in the supermarket and Frenzy Freeze sent me the clip. I was
like I knew he got shot. I didn't know he got killed and like
I just assumed because I hadn't seen everyone else freaking out.
I assumed he just got like like somebody shot at him and he got
down on the ground. It was like the Trump thing but it was like
no it was uh so I opened up the clip and it didn't say not safe
for life or anything. I just opened the clip and it was like,
"Dude, what the hell
that
Yeah, that was
Jesus."
Anyway,
>> Yeah. So, I traumatized Cherry in the >> very
market.
>> Yeah, it was [__] up. >> It's not
nihilism, dude. It's like >> No, I showed Cherry as it
as it got sent to me. I was just like, "Oh, this is apparently
Charlie Kurt getting shot." And Jesus, it was >> How is
it not nihilism? What are you talking You're saying >> Hold
I'm going to I'm going pull this >> Nihilism, dude. It's
like >> how is it not nihilism? What are you talking? You're
saying everything is >> doesn't follow the rule of law.
>> So what's the solution? So what's the solution? So what's
you want us to >> Okay, so break the law. Is that what
you're saying? Right. >> Oh, dude. Like >> are you
saying break the law? Like how? Break the law doing what? Like
what are we doing when we're >> everything Trump's doing
[__] at this point? He gets to [__] do
it. Like what Gavin Newsome, he's redistricting, right? That's
what we do. That's what we meet him. >> That's not >> that
has nothing to do with disavowing or avowing violence. You You're
doing like Yeah, you want to do like admin uh administration
or uh like procedural things to like get one up on the other
party. Okay, that's fine. But like that's way different than
shooting people in the head >> against the law. Like I
don't understand. He's doing that. We're amending the constitution.
>> To break the law has been you, Hutch. I >> You
literally just said that. Yes, you >> I know. I'm saying
that the president is breaking the law and you're asking me,
"Hey, this guy has a gun to your head about to kill you. Your
entire family, uh, can you tell me not nihilism, dude?" It's
like, >> "Oh, no. That clip, that clip cut way too early.
Hold on." >> Uh, can you tell me the legal way of how we
should do how this should not happen? It's like, what the [__]
>> So, break the law. >> So, break the law. >> No,
dude. Gome.
>> Yeah. Like, I'm sorry. I'm going to say this here. Unsubscribing
Hutch, you're
>> good. Good riddens.
This was this was like all day. This is this is hours ago. But
he made one comment about how like we should probably disavow
violence and it was all day people just being like you understand
that they they will they're going to get violent. You understand
that they're the worst, right? You understand? It's like yeah,
that's probably not what we want to focus on right now. I'm just
I'm just saying, man. Jesus. >> I can just say >> no,
I'm done with that conversation. Uh, Bobolicious with uh Five
Canadian. What specifically are we doing uh that is deescalating
the political violence in this country? Well, hosting that conversation
didn't help.
It's just very it's very funny that he's like, I just don't we
saw how mundane it was, right? He's like, I think if everybody
followed that advice and just wouldn't disow the violence, we'd
be in like a bad place. And people are coming in here. You're
pill. You're
[__] you, Hutch.
Seems a little weird, but All right. All right. I I mean, I guess
I guess that's something you could say. All right. We got one
more clip and then I'm probably going to hop into wherever this
was uh coming up next. Give me a >> Bernie Sanders doesn't
have influence.
if Barack Obama
doesn't have influence in a way that matters in a way that actually
will inspire people to cool it down a little bit or people like
Gavin Newsome or AOC if they don't have influence does destiny
have influence
so if nobody has any influence then there's no way we're out
we're going to get out of this thing right you have arrived at
the black pill you are at that point in time totally blackpilled
what you're saying is you don't think it can get matter and if
you're actually >> almost every time somebody tries to
say well actually like it has to be politicians or actually like
it has to be just media members whenever they're trying to do
that they're just trying to like everyone is influenced right
everyone is influenced in different ways and there's like some
level of decorum you should expect from people trying to like
cut it when when people do that identity slicing and dicing or
occupation slicing dicing most of the time they're just trying
to get around like some good counter example for the point they're
making they're like trying to cut it the people who provide the
best counter example It's like disingenuous arguing tactics to
be >> Black build. Then what is the point in even paying
attention to politics? Go jerk off or eat eat a lot of food and
just you know like go go take a walk a >> Just eat a lot
of food guys. >> No somebody. Okay. There there needs to
be like a school. We need like an education a summer camp or
something from like Hutch and Pisco. We need to figure out better
insults. Go go eat a lot of food.
>> Excuse me. >> Just go eat a lot of food. Okay.
You're a You're a hecking loser. You're a heck get out of here,
man. >> You You hecking loser. >> You should take
a time out or something. Okay. I think you're I think your mom
didn't really do a great job. Okay. If you want to know the truth,
>> your walk, buddy.
>> I hope it doesn't of a walk as mine >> cuz there's
a guy with a backpack. I hope there's two black dudes on your
walk. Okay, I hope there's two. >> We just play video games
all the time. Check the out. Don't even if Bernie
>> Okay, so whatever. We're We're going through this. Apparently
>> It's people calling in talking about this problem for
a really long time. >> I'm going to started
>> You don't want to make me sad? Look at my face. Look
at my face. Do you want to make me sad? >> I I don't I
don't want to see how bald you are. It's it's saddening. Okay,
listen. Hush. Okay, just for the record, it's not good to celebrate
assassinations obviously, right? Like for Luigi Manion. But at
the same time, um what you're proposing is not >> It's
actually like exactly what it is. It's exactly pragmatic.
Do you say action man? Yes, tourniquet. You're about to go off.
I get it. >> You said you weren't going to make me sad
and I'm already like immediately >> You want to make >> Don't
do the thing that's like the smart thing to do that preserves
relationships right now. Don't do that. do the emotional thing.
Be a child >> cuz at Hutch I love >> not being a
child right now is not pragmatic guys. There is nothing there
is nothing prag there is nothing there is there is nothing pragmatic
about what first of all what are you suggesting >> no can
okay let me just explain first okay yes it is you should call
out people who are celebrating Charlie Kirk's murder like how
destiny is right um hopefully that name doesn't trigger you by
the way um however u at the same time you should also acknowledge
that the right has been leaning on the left
>> wait wait Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait. That is food chops. Yes. Wait. Did this person just come
in and say Destiny did like celebrate violence? Cuz I I could
have sworn his line was that he didn't. And then he had some
vague like debate peditry or pedantry. I was I mixed and pedant.
Okay. He had some like pedantic way of defining how he wasn't
actually celebrating the whole time. >> Disavow themselves
constantly while they're constantly escalating.
They rely on this all the time. >> You know I know this
and you know you know that I know this. >> Yes, I know
that you know this. which is why he surprises me. >> I'm
with you so far. I'm with you so far. So, where do we dis where
do we
>> You should demand that Trump needs to tone down his
rhetoric. >> I'm with you so far. >> Vowing performatively
in front of >> It's not performative. That's what you're
not getting. >> It is. It is absolutely performative. What
are you talking about?
>> Just, you know, it's so performative to say that shooting
this guy in the head was bad. It's so performative. Do you think
Barco, >> By the way, Rhinox, just so you know, this is
how you sound sometimes. Okay, this is how I'm just telling you,
Rhox, I understand where you're coming from, okay? But it's not
bad to come out and say, "Yeah, shooting that guy in the head.
That was bad, actually." Or neck, >> Obama was being performative
when he put out that statement. I'm serious. Do you think he
was being perform Do you think Bernie Sanders Do you think Bernie
Do you think Bernie Sanders was being performative when he put
out that statement? Or do you think he was trying to do what
he could in the capacity of being a political leader >> during
this during Yes. Yes, I do think so. I do think so. They probably
thought in their minds, now I'm very sad. I'm not just sad. I'm
very sad. >> Hutch, why are you emotionally manipulating
me? What? Like, just Hutch, >> you made me sad. I'm telling
you the
>> Please. Okay, Hutch, listen. >> Yes, I know. I'm
also sad. Do you know why I'm sad? Because Because it sucks having
to explain this. And I know it's hard for you. Okay. Um, >> what
is the benefit? What is the benefit? What is the benefit? >> You
can't have this performative. >> Stop. Stop with the vague.
Stop with the vague. Stop interrupting >> because because
every time I ask you guys questions, it's it's so general and
vague. I want you to explain to me the value. What is the pragmatic
value of of doing what you're doing? >> It's a actually
a good point. Okay. It's actually a good point. Yeah. Just tell
me what the value is to not disavowing the violence. At at best
there, people will see that as you holding them hostage, right?
No, I'm not going to I'm not going to I'm not going to say that
that was bad until you do something I want you to do. No, I'm
not going to. Like, you're literally just You're literally just
holding them hostage. >> Sure. It forces them or it places
more pressure on them to disavow their own >> Do you think
that's going to >> How how does it do it? How, dude?
How does that ever work? This is This is an argument that only
DJs can make. Okay. Yeah. Um, when I when I tell this person
that they have to suck my if I want if they want me to put the
gun down, that's like, listen, it's just not pragmatic to put
the gun down first and ask them nicely, it's just not pragmatic.
Okay, it's not pragmatic. I don't know what to tell you. >> That
happened. >> Not right now. However, if enough people pressured
them, then yes, because like with Kilar Abrigo Garcia, like they
were pressured enough to allow that one [__] to come
in and talk to him, right? Like that's a great example that the
Trump administration actually does cater eventually to pressure,
right? They're like, "Oh, you know what? We're not going to bring
this back. Right. But that person still went through. Why? Because
of pressure. Hold on. There different kinds of pressure. You
need to differentiate between the kinds of pressure that are
happening.
No, that's what they're trying to argue right now. Marilyn plug
thug. Okay. That's what they're trying to argue is basically
we shouldn't have to disavow because it puts pressure on the
other side. It's like, yeah, but what's the pressure that you're
putting on when you refuse to disavow the violence?
The pressure is you're trying to actually apply additional violence
or sorry the the threat of additional violence to >> There's
lots of pressure because Kilmer was the perfect victim, right?
So you think of pragmatism here. Yeah. It's a solid example talking
about. >> So you think here I'm I'm going to play the tape
out. I'm just going to try to repeat back to you what I what
I think I heard from you. Okay. I've I've been told that this
is an effective way to communicate and then you can tell me if
I'm getting it wrong. All right. You think that by us saying
you know what you I am not disavowing till Donald Trump does
you think that is going to signal to uh uh that is going to be
persuasive to enough normies. >> Yes it is. It is yes it
is. It is it is >> you don't think now now what you now
what you don't >> talking about feel interrupting me. You
interrupted me.
>> You interrupting me. Hutch. Listen. Listen to me. Okay.
The thing is is that yes it is pragmatic to do that. Do you know
why? because by continuing to >> Queenman is so based on
this issue. What's Queman's opinion on this issue, Rhox? I don't
even know what his opinion would be. I can tell you K I think
the issue is there's there's like two things happening. You need
to have a public private opinion on this and it's upusion
going pushing for disavowels constantly from the left. You are
enabling their horrible escalatory behavior. It is unhinged.
Okay, just think about it. right throughout all these years.
What? I don't know why you It's just so like degenerate. It's
so
disgusting
to sit here
and soy out and go actually when you disavow violence that's
enabling their behavior. You are just advocating for using violence
against people to hurt to to like threaten them into like succumbing
to your political whims. It's it's insane. Like it's an insane
proposition. >> What do we see? We see disavows constantly,
constantly constantly. There's so many goddamn examples, Hutch.
Okay. There's so many goddamn examples of people disavowing their
own side. And where does it lead us? More violence. Like you're
telling me all these disavows eventually led up to Charlie Kirk's
assassination? Are you actually kidding me? Oh, this person is
like actually unbearable to listen to. How do people listen to
this? Like there's no It's totally incoherent.
It's totally incoherent. They're just sorting the out, right?
It's like it's like they watched uh what do you call it? It's
like they watched like um some Destiny rants and they thought
that that was like compelling and they were like what if I just
do that like all of the time but with with none of the research
that goes in with none of the inform uh being informed that goes
in just like I'll just do that and then I'll say the things that
my chat says and eventually maybe it'll work. I don't know.
Like it's it's just sad. Or do we look at the reality and we
see exactly what the playbook for what it is. An eternal victim.
An eternal enemy. The fascist playbook, right? An eternal victim.
An eternal enemy in order to in order for Trump's like [__]
to power. >> All of this all of this all of this does not
strike.
Hold on. Let me let me when >> all Hutch has to say is
like literally all of this could be true. Like they could be
fascist. They could be all of this. I can still say it was wrong
for this guy to get shot and that would still be the correct
play for me to do no matter what. had one of his right hand men
assassinated by he used that to his advantage. Yes, it was a
horrible act. Yes, it was assassination at the time. Um used
that in order to like I'm pretty sure that was before Chris.
So the thing is we are so into that point now it's just unhinged.
>> All of this >> all of this does not strike me
as coming from a measured and pragmatic point of view. All of
this to me sounds like
>> and like the societal unrest that led to Crystal Knock
and the the rise of the party is so incomparable to what's happening
in America. In America it's like dude I can't afford to go and
buy like every single day like random crazy consumer [__]
all the time and I'm not getting paid like you know a hundred
times what somebody in India is getting paid in terms of like
actual um like dollar parody. I'm not getting like all free everything
all the time. And I've I've gone from that to like I get like
30 I don't know. I I get like a 30% cut off from that. It's like
not quite all great all the time. Right. Yeah. The were the the
Wymer Republic was was disastrous. It was horrible. Right. Already
also the fascists are already in power here. Well, they're not
the same kind of fascist yet. I think they're bad. But I think
like the things that let them uh like that that let them have
the republic get like knocked down. There's nowhere near that
level of suffering in America. It just won't it it can't be the
same. >> This sounds like to me like a tantrum.
>> Like a self
like a self No, no, no. Hold on. Hold on. You are you are victimizing
yourself by positioning the act of the simple act of just condemning
political violence. Hutch Hutch could see another soy rant coming
that like meant nothing and he just No, stop. Stop. Stop soy
Like a self. No, no, no. Hold on. Hold on. You are you are victimizing
yourself by positioning the act of the simple act of just condemning
political violence. You are treating that like you are that that that
this is somehow victimizes you. If I if I if I say that, you
know, Charlie Kirk was bad, that means I'm totally fine with
them, you know, gerrymandering every state in the union, that
that's what that means. If I if I say is bad, then that's like
telling them that, yeah, take away like gay marriage, too. Take
away gay marriage, take away all of it, okay? Take away everything.
If that's they're equal >> by just being an a grown-up,
an adult who says the correct thing in this moment and you are
trying to No, hold on. Let me finish. You're You're telling me
that you think that this is going to >> Here's the thing.
I'll just I'll be real. Here's what nobody wants to tell you.
Okay. Every single person who has these positions,
if you have these positions truly that like you can't you you
need to the threat of violence, right? The threat of impending
violence to get stuff done, then I assume you have to accept
as a correlary that it is incumbent on you. It is morally correct
to do violence. Like like the the pressure from the violence
can only be so much. so long as there's not significant amounts
of it. Every single one of these people who isn't willing to
go out and commit the violence themselves, who who's like, "No,
no, no. We need the political pressure from the violence. We
won't we don't want to disavow it. We don't want to say it was
bad." Right? Every one of those people, they're total if they're
not going to go out and do the violence themselves. Okay? Either
you either you're principally committed to a to a society where
you talk through your problems or you think using violence to
pressure people into doing something you want is okay. In which
case, go ahead and do the violence yourself. Yeah. But hold on.
They're they're saying Rhox, they're saying we I want to take
advantage of the violence that's been done. I want to make the
other side scared of future violence. I don't want to disavow.
I don't want to say it's bad. I don't want to lower the temperature.
I want them to be scared. It's the exact It's just Asmin Gold's
position one to one. I think it's insane.
Persuasive to normies. You have no idea like what that response
would be if all of these Democrats in unison did what you're
suggesting. If Barack Obama and Bernie and Pete and AOC and everybody
did what you're saying and they said, "You know what? We're not
going to condemn this assassin murdering child." Hold on. Hold
on. Hold on. This is how that this is >> I'll come back
in 20 minutes.
>> This is how that's going to play out. Normies are going
to see that and they're going to go, "What the This is >> Water.
Okay. Okay. Let me Are you done? You done? You done with your
little thing? Okay. All right. Listen, Hutch. It's okay to tell
me that I'm like sping outward cuz I am sping out. Do you know
why? Cuz I'm angry. Okay. He didn't even say that. >> I'm
angry at you. >> I understand. No, you're not angry at
me. You're not angry at me. >> I hate the fact I hate the
fact and you make me sad. Hush, you make me sad on the fact that
you, by the way, get it? Cuz you use emotional manipulation,
so I'm using it, too. So, you make me sad because because
you are saying, "Oh, I'm just painting myself as the victim.
I'm the perpetual victim, not Charlie Kirk, not Charlie K's family
or whatever." Right? That's not true. What? Because um not Charlie
K. Not Charlie Chris.
You are saying, "Oh, I'm just painting myself as the victim.
I'm the perpetual victim. Not Charlie Kirk, not Charlie Cook's
family or whatever." Right. That's not true. Hutch. I >> I
can't even tell if they're saying that about Hutch.
>> They're saying that Hutch is saying that Food Shops
is making herself out to be the victim, not Charlie Kirk's family.
>> Okay. All right. Okay. Okay. I was I literally couldn't
tell. >> I am also more of a victim through Charlie Kirk's
assassination. Are you kidding me? I have been doxed Hutch. Did
you know that? Did you know that, Hutch? I've been doxed. So,
yeah. have anything to do with Charlie Kirk?
>> That's how she's a victim.
>> you don't understand. This guy lost his life, but I
laughed at it and now I'm getting doxed, so I'm the victim. >> That's
also not how they got doxed at all. But >> yeah, like of
course um like like I'm in the same boat as you. And also, not
only that, um the thing is is that you just can't allow >> Yeah.
Oh, sorry. They went and uh posted about it on Twitter, right?
They were like interacting directly with KF and Yeah. I dude
it's like not how they got >> better to get away with it
and I'm not talking about in a way where um I'm having an emotion.
>> Yeah. Also docs before Charlie died. Yes. Exactly. I
just it I don't know where. Sorry. They're saying such incoherent
things. I have no idea how to I can't follow like totally incoherent
people. I didn't realize I have like a I have like a is it like
a ceiling on my content if I'm following somebody who's totally
incoherent. I can follow Kanye. I can't follow food shops. I
can actually piece together what Kanye is saying. I can't follow
food shops at
>> Going too far. >> I'm I'm telling you, there's
a method to Kanye's madness, but this person is like ill in a
way that it's it's like they're just um >> they're just
throwing out like random clips they've seen from other people
or >> What did Kanye mean when he said, "I give my brother
head. I give my brother head. I give my brother head." >> The
cousin. And he meant he sucked his cousin's dick. That one's
not even confusing. Oh, it was his cousin.
>> Yeah. What? But what was like the what was the thing
behind that? >> That he sucked his cousin off and he was
like ashamed of it. >> Not ashamed enough that he made
that
>> Yeah. Well, he's getting through a shame, obviously.
Okay. >> Oh my god. Do I have to make rap songs? >> At
least Kanye At least Kanye's cousin was his age. If we ever get
the similar thing from food shops, we're going to hear some really
dark [__] Okay. >> Can't allow these to get
away with it. And I'm not talking about in a way where um I'm
having an emotional tantrum. I am talking about pragmatically
here because what we've tried for the last 12 years have not
worked. Obama was awesome. I agree. Obama was awesome. Joe Biden
was awesome. These people are dope. But she'll suck their dick.
Okay. But if I could, okay, I was call
what is that one woman who who sucked uh uh Bill Clinton's? I
forgot the name. Anyway, it doesn't really matter. Okay. Um uh
Monica Monica Lewinsky. Yes. like this this is like a manic episode
in like a in stream like she on speed
>> like this is actually going nuts like I don't I would
Monica Lewis they're right now okay the thing is is that they
are presidents of a prior realm of discourse the current realm
of discourse is mired in social media influence right the problem
is that you're talking about a time that is dying away fast you're
talking about a time where it is still only cable news and not
just Tik Tok and podcast bros and stuff like that, right? That
kind of [__] is what allows misinformation and horribleness
to spread much faster. Okay? Because now that everyone has been
plugged in, everyone gets to hear right-wing talking points.
What am I listening to? This is uh Destiny's number one orbiter,
the person he like uh raids every night and goes and joins the
Discord of to talk about politics with and this is them like
trying to shame Hutch for saying that
condemning violence is good. So she's come on apparently a bunch
of DJs called in to like shame Hutch for saying condemning violence
is the is the play and now she's come in to do the same
>> Some very odd stuff. >> This is the new Dan.
>> Is food Jewish?
Uh, no. But maybe the new Dan. Yeah, sure. That makes some sense.
>> Every day about how there's like civil war going on,
about how a genocide is coming to the right wing. How is that
acceptable to you? >> You're communicating. >> It
is. >> That feels like a hell of a straw, man. Like, if
you think that I'm not aware of the stakes, I I feel like you're
you're implying that I don't understand the stakes and how serious
things are right now. But everything that you just said, you're
just describing how bad things are. you're not really responding
to my point. The idea that if you had all Democrats in unison
say we're not going to disavow
until Trump does that is going to uh cause uh the opposite reaction
of what you're suggesting. It is not pragmatic. Normies will
see that and think what the what is going on with the Democratic
party right now and it's not fair and there is a double standard.
I understand but you are not hold on >> Ruben donated $3
food shops is Jewish.
>> Okay. Thank you very much Ruby Rubenizing yourself by
simply acknowledging that political violence is not acceptable
in a liberal society. You are not yourself. If you if you hesitate
hold on wait if you hesitate to affirm the principles that you
claim to believe in. If you hesitate to affirm those principles
because you're afraid that you think it's going to give your
enemy a W, you are you're not looking at the situation through
a pragmatic lens at >> Oh god. What? Hutch is speaking
sense. What? Hutch. Hutch being like reasonable and intelligent
right now. That's >> All you are looking at it through
a hyperartisan lens. >> Hutch. I am looking
if you want to call my position hyper uh hyper partisan that's
fine but I'm just matching the Republicans's energy right the
thing is is that that is pragmatic that is actually pragmatic
because by playing on the same playing field by no longer playing
by the rules you are displaying to them that you it's kind of
the rules apply to like political decisions how political operatives
should operate it's not about assassinations that's the thing
this person is trying to take Josiah's argument right Josiah's
argument that he convinced Destiny of and Destiny totally stole
cuz he has no unique thoughts of his own is hey stop being like
kind to these politicians. Stop being civil to these politicians.
They're not civil. They are using the veil of civility to attack
you. Stop being civil and actually just like go after them in
the same way. That's Josiah's point. That's this person is bastardizing
Josiah's point. Okay? Because none of that applies to assassinations
or or political violence.
You don't do it at that point. You don't go, "Oh, wait. Well,
you guys like laughed at Paul Pelosi, so I'm not going to until
you say you disavow violence, I won't disavow violence. Guess
what? Charlie Kirk's
Charlie Kirk's dead. Okay,
Charlie Kirk is dead. And you have to deal with that. You have
to deal with how I I don't know what I have to say beyond Republicans
are obviously using people celebrating his death as political
messaging right now, right? Like they're very happy to use that
as political messaging. Why lean into that? Why give your enemy
exactly what they want? And I don't know. I don't know how else
to say this. If you think that the average Republican or average
populist, you know, influencer has less of a finger on the pulse
of normal people than people like food shops or Destiny, you're
insane. You're going to put off all of the normal people, okay?
You're going to actually make that make it so they will want
nothing to do with you. Don't trust Don't trust those people,
okay? Don't trust these totally like socially aberant weirdos
to tell you how to interact in a way that satisfies the masses
or wins you elections because they are just that. They are antisocial
weirdos. They don't have any idea of how to talk to normal people.
They don't have any idea what looks good to normal people. Do
not trust them in terms of electoral politics whatsoever.
Kind of like looking in the reflection for them, right? They
look at themselves and they're horrified about what they see.
But that's been them all along. They can't self-reflect on their
own. They can't introspect on their own. The only way is to hold
up a mirror to them. The mirror is us, right, Hutch? The thing
is is that what you're proposing, you say is pragmatic over and
over and over again. I agree with you. It's pragmatic. If it
was still 15 years ago, if it was 15 years ago, I fully agree
with you. George Bush era, you know, that kind of right. Obviously,
political violence should be it should be condemned abort or
whatever the but right now we've seen that for the last 12 years,
we've been losing, losing, losing, and I'm tired and sick. That's
not true. It is tiring. >> It's not true. >> The
the what you just said is not true. >> Uh food shops didn't
care about politics like at all and they were totally just a
drama streamer. This is just like skinwalking. It's not anything
real. Um like as of a couple months ago had no concern about
politics whatsoever. And now she's sitting here trying to tell
Hutch, "Hutch, I'm tired of losing. I'm tire Hutch, I've been
doing a lot of work on politics. I'm tired of losing. You're
still a boomer. >> What you just said is not true. What
you just said is not true. We've done nothing but lose for the
last 12 years." It's not true.
>> It's not true. >> Joe Biden won once. Okay. But
>> no, no, no. It wasn't just Joe Biden won once. You realize
You realize he should have had a landslide of a landslide, right?
Like you realize after a Trump first term, he should have had
the king of all landslide. >> I've had a bit more time.
I've had a bit more time. >> Biden one was like pretty
huge. You would have expected a bigger red wave. >> They
were talking about the red uh the It wasn't even the red wave.
It was like the red tsunami. They were like, "Oh, we're going
to like crush this." And they they underperformed like pretty
>> Yeah, they underperformed pretty badly. >> Extremely
bad. Yeah. >> Yeah.
Oh, hold on. Oh, do we say >> I've had a bit more time
than you. I've had a bit more time than you to accept that uh
you know, this country's [__] in a lot of ways. So,
it just doesn't make that part doesn't make me as >> No,
Major Dr. Gastley, she was not a political streamer. She was
always a drama streamer. >> Even back then, she like the
whole thing was queen farming her over drama
>> Yeah. She talked about prescribing herself Lolly
>> to deal with PD talk to like the Thorps and like that.
What? Hold on. I'm getting uh just real quick now that I paused.
Wait, she she talked to the >> That's weird. I remember
her conversation with Andrew.
>> Okay. Did Did you ever see her conversation with the
Thorps?
>> No. I remember having to kick her off of my panel a
couple times cuz she wanted to turn it into a show. >> Uh
Grace Politics was boring. >> Uh food shops. I never had
Grace on cuz she wouldn't come on without her dad. Gross. Okay.
I didn't even know you had food chops on. That's crazy. Just
real quick, uh, quick tweet.
>> Charlie in the Chocolate Factory.
These two got along quite well, didn't they? Jeez. Jeez. >> Pull
up my thing, too. Wait. >> People making some assumptions
here. >> I remember telling you that it makes sense for
Candace to have like really felt bad about Charlie Kirk cuz they
were good friends. And it's also because they both were like
pretty high up with TPUSA. So, it's I think it's one of those
things where you became friends because you were both in um a
similar space together, right? >> Sure. Yeah. Sure. They're
actual >> Yeah. There's like a video of the them and then
some other white guy singing R. Kelly. And um >> wait,
is this this isn't real, right? This is photoshopped. This got
to be photoshopped. This looks like it's
>> That's got to be photoshopped, right? Neo just put that
in chat. I'm pretty confident that's photoshopped.
I know Candace and Kanye are close or they were close. I don't
know about
>> I'm pretty sure it's real.
Huh. The gang's all here. Oh boy. That's uh that's interesting.
Okay. Wait, what was your what was the tweet you linked to >> Tom
Bronson made it. You finished it >> Figured out what happened
to FBI director Cash Mattel. How do you feel now? I I can't move.
Sink into the
>> It's so good. And he did such a good
>> That's amazing. Oh, that's awesome. You might need a
fourth frame here. Okay. Fourth frame that just shows him like
staring out like terrified into the distance. Okay.
Yes. >> You mean just his face? >> Yeah, just his
face. But like in real life like sitting at the press conference
just like a thousand yard stare into the distance. He's just
totally locked out.
Jesus. Okay. >> I don't get it. Sha
Shel Shulk. Have you ever seen the movie Get Out? >> So,
we were joking about how yesterday he looks like the guy when
the photo goes off in Get Out and his eyes just go like wide,
>> right? He looks like he's experiencing that moment all
the time. Like he's in the sunken place and he can only communicate
through the terror his terror in his eyes. Okay. He his eyes
are the only things he controls at this moment. And so he's he's
constantly like showing his terror. Show the pick. Which
>> People who are audio only. They're trying to catch up
to the meme. >> Hold on. >> Yeah. So, it's the lady
with the teacup who's spinning the spoon. That lady's Hillary
Clinton.
Trump is sitting next to her
>> and she's putting him under. Cash Patel. She She's putting
Cash Patel under. >> You don't think through his eyes,
>> but chatting is crazy. Yeah. I don't think you can see
the the video very clearly
if you used your phone to chat. Oh my god. He does look like
he's seen some like always >> just all the time. all the
time he's rocking this look is crazy. All right, we uh Wait,
wait, wait. Yeah, the Sorry. The Charlie Kirk stuff was just
All right. All right.
adultery is a sin. They'd never do that. Okay, they'd never do
that. That would be wild.
We will cover Candace a little bit more later and her sort of
taking shots at Nick, I think. Did she delete one of her tweets?
cuz she had a tweet about hatred and then she but I think that's
gone.
>> If anybody's got the tweet about how she was like sorry
that she's been so hateful recently. I think she deleted that
tweet. Unless I'm Oh, no. No. No. No. I have it. >> I got
it. >> I spoke to for an hour. Oh, you got it. >> Yeah,
I got it. I got it. All right. All right. Okay. Let's get back
to this. See, your video is ironically the most humanizing thing
I've seen so far. Nope. Didn't see it. sad and angry as it does
maybe you because I've just had a lot more time to get used to
it. I'm 42 I'm 42 years old. >> Okay. I'm 26. I'm old.
>> I've had I've had a lot I've had a lot more time to
get used to it. Okay. And I remember being a lot more angry when
I was younger. So I
>> Yeah. I feel like the mustache is stylish when like
you're a young fellow
and you grow out that mustache and you keep it. I think uh if
you have blonde hair, the beard is always tricky unless you can
grow it out like really thick. Like you can't you can't have
like a dusting of facial hair when you're blonde like really
really blonde. I don't think it just looks odd. It like it doesn't
really I don't know. Or you need maybe you need to be like very
tan or something. Maybe that's what it is. I'm not totally sure.
Who is this Hutch guy anyway? Never heard of him. He's um like
a liberal politics streamer. came from Call of Duty like 15 years
ago. This guy was like the best Call of Duty player or something.
He used to stream Call of Duty. He was like one of the early
COD content creators and then he did that for a long time and
eventually he worked his way into doing political coverage. One
of the few people who was like able to pivot out of that niche,
I guess, into something tangible. >> I understand. I do.
I understand that. But I I'm telling you like do you have like
normie people in your life that are not super engaged in politics?
>> My parents.
>> Anybody else? >> Uh no. I'm sure I'm sure food
jobs has a great relationship with your parents.
>> I because I would want you to like talk to normies and
just kind of run it >> like like my old political friends.
I >> I I would want you to like talk to normies cuz I know
if I asked like my normie people that I have in my life cuz >> This
is by the way this is like when when people come and tell you
like how normal people take things and you're like wait like
who? And they're like oh I don't know any. It's it's a rough
moment. Okay. It's it's tough. It's >> A lot of normies
that are just not engaged in politics and I can tell you with
1,000% certainty and a lot of these people, most of them are
left-leaning. If I if I went to them and I told them like, "Hey,
what what would you what would you think about like this, you
know, like what what would you say if every every, you know,
Democrat said that they refused to disavow violence until uh
Trump did?"
The answer the response that I'm going to get for them is they
would think that that was really bad. They would not approve
of that. >> It would damage us. It would damage us. It
would damage us politically. It is politically not smart. >> Hush.
Hush. You realize I recognize that, right? Does that make sense?
>> No. What do you mean? You just said it was pragmatic.
>> We don't. We No. No. No. No. No. No. On the part of
how people would respond to it IRL. We don't disagree on that.
You realize that, right? >> Okay. So, okay. Reconcile your
strategy with what I'm saying then.
Is she disagreeing? Did she just go, "Yeah, I don't know anybody
IRL, but uh I disagree with you." That's not what just happened.
Did I misunderstand this? >> Sorry, I'm also getting sent
screenshots of uh apparently Charlie Kirk had met Kanye. Okay.
Apparently, this is very real. The exact scene we looked at,
very real. Different angle on the same shot.
>> they did meet up multiple times apparently. Multiple
times. >> The time
where they were doing something about like the vote or it's like
okay to be white. I have no idea what time this was at. >> Yeah,
I think this is around the time where him and Candace were wearing
like white power t-shirts. Obviously not in these photos. I'll
have to find it. But um Hutch just got food shops to admit that
she said it was pragmatic. And then when Hutch is like, "Well,
we would lose them. This is like so bad for them." She's like,
"Yeah, we're not disagreeing. That would happen, too."
You can't say both of those things,
What? Okay. I I'll be honest. I can't I have a hard time processing
people like this. Maybe I I was thinking that she was like, "Oh,
going to say you were wrong." Hold on. I have to go back a little
bit and listen. >> What do you mean? You just said it was
>> We don't. We No, no, no, no, no, no. On the part of
how people would respond to it IRL, we don't disagree on that.
You realize that, right? >> Okay. So,
uh, people would be totally off-put by this, but you know, I
don't even So, she just she just conceded the entire argument
to Hutch. It's not >> And she conceded that she's incorrect.
>> I This person is so worthless. This person's contributions
to everything are so worthless. >> You would just have
to say that this person just wants to be like,
what would you call it? Like an obstructionist. I don't even
like if you wanted to be an obstructionist, you would be more
effective.
Like they just want they're like um they're like Connor in sorry
no Connor was obstructionist. So hold on that
they like just they're just an exhibitionist. They just want
to go out and get as much attention as possible for as long as
possible with no long-term strategy whatsoever. >> Like
an exhibitionist I think is a better example or a better word
for >> And Hutch is giving her that. It's really nice of
Hutch to partake in this person's kink. >> It is. It is
very kind of Hutch to do that. Um, oh, it's I don't think Destiny
cleans up their arguments normally. I don't think that's true.
Sidonia or sorry, Zenali is spite base. I think they're just
trying to echo Destiny without understanding any of the underlying
points and they're like getting way off base. Like totally off
Um, they're not good at arguing this at all. This is what happens
when you don't understand any of the conversations, but you try
to copy what somebody else's what somebody else says. I think
>> okay reconcile your strategy with what I'm saying then.
>> Okay. Who who which base are you appealing to next election?
Is it the >> It's both moderates and the base in in terms
of in terms of >> right now >> Wait, hold on. >> The
problem with >> Hold on. I I just we need to we need to
>> Hang on. You're agreeing with me that most normies,
the people that are kind of like not very dis like people like
you and me and a lot of people in my chat, we consume political
content every day. The vast majority of the country are not doing
this. Okay? They're not. There's a lot of people that are kind
of basically apolitical and it's all vibes and it doesn't really
matter. And I'm telling you, if you go out and you talk to normies,
people that are not engaged, and if you if you told them, "Hey,
what would you think if Barack Obama said he he wouldn't disavow
Charlie Kirk's murder until Donald Trump did, every like almost
every single normie that you run that by?" They're going to be
like, "That would be der deranged." >> We don't disagree
that this uh we don't disagree with the descriptive. You realize
that? >> Okay. So then you have to >> you have to
disagree with the descriptive. You have to you you have to
Hutch is saying okay well listen if we take if we adopt this
position we're actually completely and food chops is like yeah
I don't disagree. I don't disagree. This is put off everybody
we need to get the votes of. Yes. This would like totally ruin
us. It's like okay but you just said it was pragmatic to ruin
your reputation with all these people to totally ruin it completely.
So explain that. explain that to me at all. >> Come to
my conclusion where this is the only even if you disagree even
if you disagree with like the morality of it politically it's
smart to disavow violence. Do you want to win? Do you want to
build a coalition and win? >> Yes, it's good to disavow
violence obviously, but you shouldn't do it performatively in
front of >> What does that mean? Like these guys
Okay, hold on. They I I've not watched the Destiny stuff. There's
no way that he's had this position because if you guys don't
hear this translation, it is entirely while I'm not listen while
it is bad. While I do actually principally disagree with this,
I I principally disagree with violence. I will not disavow this
group in front of people who don't care about the underlying
issue. Do you know what that exact abstraction applies to? Because
it's one to one. Anybody recognize that? cuz I've watched somebody
do some really stupid lack of disavowels in front of the entire
world, the entire political world, the entire drama world and
he looks like a but it is his position and it's the exact same.
So I don't know if these people It's very ironic. Okay, anybody
hear what anybody see what I'm cooking? Anybody know? I'm just
waiting to see if anybody can understand it real
>> Okay, what are you cooking? This is the exact exact
exact
one to one of Hassan [__] Hassan [__]
saying, "Well, I'm not going to disavow the Houthies. I don't
think you should actually like kidnap I I don't think you should
kidnap civilians, but I will not disavow the Houthies in front
of somebody who doesn't even care about the genocide. They're
just trying to they're just trying to distract from the genocide,
right? So, these people are making Hassan's argument one to one
right now. And they are admitting that that is a good argument
to make. So any any
performative virtue signal you do food shops or if Destiny is
making the same argument Destiny about Hassan is totally moot
now. You've lost it. You've lost your high ground if this is
the argument you want to make. Oh no. I'm not going to do the
thing that even though I dis even though I agree with it, even
though I think violence is bad, right?
Even though I think violence is bad, I'm not going to say in
front of you cuz you don't care about this at all. You're just
you're just trying to get me to say it. That's exactly what Hassan
thinks. That's what exactly how Hassan acts, right? this his
exact point with disavowing the Houthies is exact one to one.
So I just I think that would be crazy. Sorry. >> How would
somebody walk away from that? >> I said, "Okay, how would
someone walk away from that position if they realized now, okay,
if I have this position, then I'm kind of a hypocrite against
Hassan or the things that I say I don't like about Hassan.
>> you just have to take it back." >> Sorry, ask
that again from the start. Okay. So, for food shops right now
to believe what they're believing, um, they wouldn't be able
to have any criticism for Hassan.
>> Well, not real criticism.
>> Yeah. Not real criticism. They'd just be a hypocrite.
And the only way to uh resolve that is to take this back essentially,
right? >> Well, take back this use of this argument. If
you think this argument is valid that you can't criticize Hassan,
>> then Hassan like I think this argument is stupid. Personally,
I think you do it. You have to be of the belief that you need
to publicly disavow the
the
publicly disavow the murder of a political pundit. And if you
can't do that, you probably can't have heat for Hassan for what
he's doing. >> For the Houthy thing. Yeah. Exactly.
>> Cuz cuz Hassan does disavow in different segments, in
different places, he will say, "No, no, no. Kidnapping civilians,
that's wrong. Kidnapping civilians is wrong." And doing But it's
the exact same like abstract thing. He's saying, "Well, in front
of you, I'm not going to do it cuz you're just trying to change
the conversation from like the genocide is like his argument."
And they're like, "Oh, well, you're trying to, you know, politically
signal with this in a way that like makes me stop um stop criticizing
Republicans." It's like, no, you can actually say violence is
bad and Republicans are deranged at the same time. I've never
once said in anything we've done on here, "Oh, no. Actually,
criticizing Charlie Kirk's positions is wrong. You shouldn't
do that." I've never said that. Never will say that. Right. Yeah.
Anyway,
so all right. Hassan is literally admitted to hiding his power
level in front of an army is not the same thing. >> Oh,
I found those photos. It's not white supremacy or white power.
It's white lives matter. >> Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Well, I knew it was white lives matter. Yeah. That this
is the shirt she was wearing. She got Kanye to wear it, but I
don't remember when Charlie I don't know when this was and I
don't know when they would have hung out. >> So, around
that time. Um, this is like around the BLM protests. >> Okay.
All right. But I don't like the Charlie Kirk stuff, too. Yeah,
because she um she was with TP USA around that time, so that's
when they would have all linked together.
>> Okay.
They if they would have had Charlie in this photo, it would have
been a banger.
I can't believe they missed out on it. Would have been awesome
stuff. >> Oh, I'm No, not So, the photo where they're hanging
out with Charlie is probably a different day, but this is um
around that time period when they were all mingling and stuff
like that. >> Yeah. Okay, got it. I That's the weirdest
combo to me still. I can't. I guess it's not the weirdest combo.
It's like all Yeah, Assad is bad. Assan is bad. We missed a couple
of them. All right, we did. We did. Let's get back to this guy.
My position is So, so the thing is is that yeah, on your own
time, you should be able to disavow violence. There's nothing
wrong with that. But the thing is is that um when you're in front
of a conservative, they're also putting on a performance, right?
What they're doing is that they're using this as an excuse to
paint Charlie Kirk as a martyr in order to escalate violence.
Are we just seeing Wrangler start with 2.56 million subscribers
saying that we need to trade in a sword like the modern version
of a sword is a AR-15 and you need to be go in to like like kill
anybody who is like causing shootings or something like to run
into schools and >> hey wait who's uh this guy referring
to
because the police won't help anyone. >> Can you be Can
you Can you be more specific? How could you >> can you
be more specific when you say specific when you say when you
say
can you be more specific in the sense of like don't do it in
front of Republicans? What does that mean? Does a public does
a public tweet count as in front of Republicans?
>> So like for example, if you're on the Pierce Morgan
panel and you have uh conservative pundits looking at you and
they're like, "Okay, but do you disavow the violence?" Say, "No,
I refuse to until you do it first for Donald Trump." And if you
show that video to politically disengaged normies,
you don't think the vast majority of them that see that are going
to interpret that to be even if what you're saying is like technically
like true. Even if your reasoning is sound, even if that double
standard is real, if you show that video on Piers Morgan, if
you saying, "You know what? You know what? No, I'm not going
to do it." Like what do you think the majority of people are
going to have? Like how do you think the response is going to
be? >> Which one? The Piers Morgan video or the >> Yeah.
If you showed like a a bunch of normies, you know, footage of
somebody on a Piers Morgan panel saying, "I'm not going to do
it until Trump does." What do you think a majority of normies
are going to think when they see that? >> Um, they're probably
going to think, "Yeah, this guy is uh pretty somewhat unhinged,
right?" Yeah, of course.
>> Then you have to agree with me. You have to agree with
me. No, no, no, no, no. >> He hasn't even made his argument
yet.
Okay. So, they they're going to think it's unhinged. So, you
have to agree with me that No, wait. I haven't said No, no. I
I don't have to. No. No.
No. No. You can't. You can't. This is just this is cuz this is
cognit this is literally the this is the definition of cognitive
dissonance. You're wrong. You are wrong. You're wrong. >> You
are wrong. >> Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Let me know when you're
done. >> It's not just about moderates. It's about normies.
>> Uh okay. You go on your rant. Let me know when you're
done. >> Let's be more spe Let's be Let's be more general
and broad enough to encompass all the people that I'm talking
about. Normies. That's what we're talking about. Normies are
really important in national elections.
They're super important.
>> Yeah, I agree with you. >> Then you have to take
my position. >> Yeah, but for the last 12 years, it hasn't
been working. So, the evidence is on my side. Like, what are
you talking >> You just agreed with me. Hang on a >> The
last 12 years put you like squarely in the middle of Obama's
presidency.
Like squarely in the middle of Obama's
>> You just agreed with me that it would turn off most
normies if they saw that. >> Yeah. Focus. The thing is
is that we can't have the same standard. We just can't have the
same standard anymore. We keep on appealing to normies and the
>> No, I could have sworn 12 years ago put you in 2013,
a year after the exact midpoint of Obama's presidency, but maybe
not. >> Republicans keep escalating the rhetoric and they
keep winning elections. Like, what are you talking about? >> This
is not This is not pragmatic. >> Third term. >> You're
not desri You're not being pragmatic. No, you're throwing a
>> That's what you're doing. >> I'm having the future
in mind and that is part >> No, you're not though. You
just said you just said that most normies would be turned off
and yet you're still saying that you should do that. That's co
that's literal just like the definition of cognitive dissonance.
That's what that is. >> You are holding two contradictory
beliefs in your mind at the same time. >> Hold on. Wait,
Rhox, you're getting you're getting like so mad. You could just
say violence is bad and then go on to say all of the other things.
People think that you can't you can't push back against Charlie
Kirk being a martyr or the lionization of Charlie Kirk without
disavowing violence. You can do both very easily.
I've been doing so on this stream the entire time. The idea that
you can't go, "Oh yeah, shooting that guy is wrong." And also
say also, he is an extremist. He was like crazy. Everybody who's
lying about him now and saying, "Oh, this guy just wanted to
go to colleges and talk or or talk to students and change people's."
That's that's not how he was. That's not how that's not how he
was. That's not how it was. That's not what his movement was
about. His movement was about creating large-scale change in
his political direction across the country. And he was successful
in that. question. I have a question. I have a question. I have
a question. What did you think the normies thought when uh Donald
Trump's son did the Halloween costume for Paul Pelosi? What do
you think they thought? What do you think? >> 95 I think
95.
>> I think 95% of them didn't even [__] see
that. >> How you say what >> do you think they think?
>> What do you think they think? No. What do you think
they thought?
>> That's not how you say that. Yeah, that's not how you
say that. >> Okay.
Most normies, how many How many of them do do you think could
even >> Wait, did he actually get a chance to >> I
think 95% Why did they overturn? >> I think 95% of them
didn't even [__] see that. Most normies, how many
How many of them do do you think could even tell you a lot about
the attack on Paul Pelosi, let alone let alone Don Jr.'s >> Pelosi
attack. >> You think most >> What are you talking
about? >> That's Hud is going to make the obvious point
here where that really only echoed in political circles. A lot
of people didn't really care about It was jokes amongst political
people. Um, Charlie Kirk's shooting was like headline news for
what is still headline news today, right? It taps into like a
million other different issues. You're see everybody's seeing
this. Every single person in America actually possibly every
single person in the world is seeing it. There is no go
sitting in soul Korea going I am Paul Pelosi. Actually, I am
Paul Perosi. I am Paul Pelosi. That didn't happen. Okay, that
didn't happen. So why are you pretending it's the same thing?
>> You think most political normies in this country could
tell you about Don Jr.'s tweet about Paul Pelosi?
>> It was an Instagram post. >> And you think most
normies know about >> That's the problem is because No,
but that's the problem. That's why the tides need to turn. We
need to make the media notice the [__] double standards.
We need to make the media put more pressure on the Republicans.
But you but you just
>> Oh, and do you think the best way to do that is by refusing
to disavow violence now? You want to refuse to disavow violence
and then go, "Look, they won't do it." They're just going to
go, "Yeah, look at look at this unhinged telling us to who wouldn't
it? You have no leg to stand on whatsoever." >> I don't
necessarily know that you need a leg to stand on cuz technically
Republicans don't ever have a leg to stand on. It might just
be offense, offense, offense. But I'm saying that like it's not
like it helps it. There is no downside to saying shooting this
guy was bad. There's zero downside.
There's only upside. Said >> a Democrat. If a Democrat
has done the hammer tweet, if a Democrat has done the hammer
tweet, do how much attention do you think he'll get? >> Wall
to-wall coverage. Wall to-wall >> Exactly. How is that
acceptable to you?
>> I'm not saying it is. I'm not saying it >> But
you're not starting the fight to push back when the Democrats
disavow again and again. >> So again, the fight to push
back here is you need a time machine. You need to go make a big
row about Paul Pelosi. If something like this happens to a Democrat
or somebody who's Democrat aligned, you need to make a big deal
of it. You need to make everything political. That's what you
should be arguing. You don't have to argue, oh, we have to go
back now. We have to like disavow we we can't disavow violence.
This is like the most argument you could make. This is the most
This is the most
moronic argument you could possibly make. That doesn't win elections.
Elections take energy. Election take energized voters. That's
the problem. You can't >> Is this person like regressing
to
>> fight to push back? When the Democrats disavow again
and again, that doesn't win elections. Elections take energy.
Election take energized voters. That's >> election take
energized voters. Election take energy. Election take energized
>> Problem. You can't get Let's rewind
feeling selfshame. >> Let's let's It's not about shame.
It's not about shame. You are attaching shame to No, it's not.
This has had nothing to do with shame. When Barack You think
Barack Obama when he put that tweet out, you think he was projecting
shame? Like, I'm so ashamed.
>> That's what you think? >> You are wrong. You are
wrong. >> The collectiveness of the of the Democratic party.
It's not him specifically, but it's him trying to be the spokesperson
because he's the figurehead of >> Let's rewind. Let's rewind.
>> It is. Is that >> Let's rewind. Let's rewind the
clock. Um, back to 2020. Okay. uh uh the the the riots happen,
right? And what do we see from the Democrats? Unequivocal con
condemnation from the top down. AOC condemned the rioting. Kamla
did. Biden did. Pelosi did. Every prominent national Democrat
um disavowed the rioting. What do you think would have And that
was a close election. That was a really close election. Do you
think Joe Biden Wait, hold on. Let me finish the question. Let
me finish the >> Joe Biden won twice. >> Let me let
me finish the question. Do you think that counter is >> Do
you think that Joe Biden would have won that election if every
single Democrat refused to condemn the writing until Donald Trump
condemns like rightwing violence? You're being in hindsight,
Andy, because >> Just answer the question. Just answer
the question. >> I don't know. >> We've lost for
12 years. We've lost for 12 years in a row. I'm sick of it. Also,
you're being a hindsight, Andy. >> Oh, the question The
answer is I don't know because you're going back in time and
is seeing a alternate timeline. Are >> What does your heart
tell you, >> dude? What we should have I should have probably
pulled up food shop's side of this where she's like reading a
chat with this or something where it's like totally obvious that
she's just getting chat messages from others
cuz there's just no coherence to that's why she'll make like
10 different arguments in the same thing, right? Like she's making
she's making multiple different arguments and none of them coales
into one coherent line of thought. It's why she's arguing. Well,
it's the pragmatic thing not to disavow. But also, Normies will
be totally put off. But also, yeah, I did say it was pragmatic.
And also, I admit now that it wasn't pragmatic. And she doesn't
even connect that she's like she's actually conceded her real
argument. The argument she was making originally, it doesn't
even hit for her that she just did that. Like, everyone's confused.
>> Alternate timelines. What does your heart tell you?
>> That's actually the reality of the What does my heart
tell me? I think that Joe Biden Wait, wait. When When did that
happen? When did George Floy that happened before Biden's win,
right? 2020. It was the summer before 2020. It was like five
months before. What do you think would have happened if Joe Biden
and every single Democrat said, "You know what? We're not going
to condemn the rioting till Donald Trump condemns like violence
on the right." >> Do you think he would have >> Oh,
hold on. Hutch needs to because this is how you argue with DJs.
Okay. Hutch needs to go find some Destiny quotes about the rioting
and how badly it needed to stop. Is there a famous quote here,
guys? Is there a famous quote from Destiny about how bad the
rioting was optically for the country to like win the election?
I feel like there might be a famous quote somewhere that could
convince her of like why it's important to disavow violence in
terms of election outcomes possession.
>> Well, the answer is I don't know, right? And I'm telling
you this from the heart. The reason from the heart is because
Okay. Yeah. Go ahead. Yeah. Mr. Doctor >> I can tell you
with a thousand% certainty he would have lost that >> turn.
Okay. Mr. Green. >> That's not what that term means. with
a thousand% certainty. >> I don't mean that Biden would
have lost that election. The Democrats lost seats in the House
that year. Do you know why? And it was a big reason why they
lost >> Why? Why? Hutch. I'm coming. I'm coming. >> The
rioting.
>> Oh, I came. Dude, Hutch, the thing is is
>> Yeah. I What? >> I I'll just point out again.
This >> Can he Can he look shocked or disgusted that somebody
is speaking to him like that for a political debate? Um, also
this person does just like uh talk down to Hutch as well and
he like doesn't do anything. He's just like whatever.
I like I can understand with somebody he wants to maintain but
like this person's like a totally deranged disgusting lunatic.
Like there's just no reason to maintain anything there. Very
odd very odd behavior.
>> How is the standards equal? We have January 6. >> It's
not happened. It's not equal. >> Then Trump won the election.
What are you talking about? How is that not so much worse than
the rule? >> There is a double standard. I've told you
this the whole time. >> 99%. We're just >> There
is a double standard. >> Wait, what did most Republican
politicians do when that happened? I'm tell I'm telling you most
Republican politicians came together and disavowed that right
right after right off the bat. It took a lot a long time for
people to come back and start like actually going, "Well, was
it really that bad?" It took them like massaging that with their
what do you call it? their political apparatus for a long time
before Republican politicians came back and said, "No, you know
what? Maybe maybe they kind of overblue that a little bit >> protest
and 1% violent protest." Like, how is that fair? >> There
is a double standard. I already told you I believed in that.
>> Yeah. So, the thing is is that so the Democrats did
what you wanted them to do, right? By the way, just the way to
fix that double standard is to be aggressive when the other side
up. When the other side has a bad moment, it's to be aggressive
and it's to take every single moment and weaponize it maximally.
It's not about how you act when your side does something bad.
You can totally disavow when your side does something bad. If
somebody shoots, you know, if somebody for the sake of political
speech shoots a, you know, massive Republican influencer, you
can go, "Oh, that's bad." Right? The issue is when when little
things happen, when Republicans do little things, you need to
actually take that and blow it up into something, right? If you
want to play that game, I don't think that works because I think
that's the populist game and I don't think the Democrats are
the I don't think Democrats are the party of populism. But if
you want to if you want to play that game, that's how you play
it. You attack attack attack. You don't go and say, "Oh, no.
Actually, I won't disavow the violence here." You don't. That's
not the play, >> right? Which is disavow. And then they
still lost. That literally >> they won. But no, it does
not. >> By your own standards, by your own you, the Democrats
disavowed that you still said by your end that they've lost House
seats, right? >> Cuz 2024 had nothing 2024 had nothing
to do with the 2020 riots. The 2020 election happened literally
>> talking about it has everything to do. Do you know why?
>> No, it does not. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
Let's Let's take it down a notch. Let's take down the temperature.
>> Is it true? >> Let's take down the temperature
just for a minute. Okay, calm down with me. Okay, I'm going to
be really calm. In 2020, that election took in 2020. >> How
was your day? How was your day? >> It was real bad because
because it was real bad because you guys have made me sad. But
if we go back to the 2020 election No, no, no, no. Hold on. Let
me make my point. Let me make my Seriously. Oh, okay. The the
weird
uh it just it's so if these people could just act like humans
instead of actually actually Wait, how was your day? How was
your day, bro? You've just been like screaming at this guy. You've
just been like like you're It's so weird watching them act like
a lizard the whole time and then they try to act like a human
>> I want to chill. >> Let me make my point. Okay.
In 2020 that >> this is this is really what we should say.
It's the talking down, right? It's the It's the talking down
like she is better than Hudge. She's less informed than Hush.
She's less intelligent than Hudge. And I'm not a big fan of Hudge,
right? But she's like still talking down to him like he's wrong
on this. No, he's he's correct. And at minimum, he's more correct
than you are. You can't explain why you think anything you do.
I It's crazy. Happened months after the rioting. Okay. It was
top of mind for a lot of people. A lot of voters all over the
country were freaked out by defund the police and uh they were
they were they were horrified by the rioting. >> Reban
Rubin donated $3. There must be a lot of soy based products in
that food >> Thank you for the three Ruben Ruben. Appreciate
it. >> And uh you know we barely won that election and
we lost seats in the house and we know for a fact that the rioting
played a part in that. Okay.
Joe Biden. >> Yeah. Like Uncle Nick kind of has it. Okay.
You need to document all of the [__] they're doing
with the cancel culture because that will fade. The momentum
from that will fade. But you know what won't fade is getting
those getting like a waitress fired from Olive Garden or some
[__] Okay, that's the kind of that people will be
pissed about for a long time. That's the kind of thing you can
get people behind, right? Oh, she tweeted like wamp wamp and
you got her fired from her [__] job. Yeah, that's
insane. The anger from Charlie Kirk's passing will not stay,
right? But the anger from getting people fired for like minor
like for being dismissive of like the lionization,
that's crazy. Don't let that [__] go.
He won by a 40,000 vote margin spread across three states. That
was a razor thin margin. If he and the rest of the Democrats
had not disavowed that violence, he would have lost that election.
In 2024, people were not thinking about they were thinking about
the economy and they were thinking about inflation. They weren't
thinking about like the riots in 2020. >> I came to an
answer. Okay, ready? I came to an answer. The thing is is that
yes, because it was so soon at the time, then yeah, you should
have like disavowed them thoroughly. Absolutely. You should absolutely
disavow it. >> I thought that was >> But the thing
is, >> the problem is the problem is is that it's still
Do you know why? It's because we spread that disavowel into 2025.
The year is 2025 and the Republicans are >> what's the
why do we got to do Justin Justin Trudeau?
Don't do current C current year was always gay. Don't do current
year. >> Still talking about the riots. They still bring
up BLM. They still bring up how the country is turning more and
more violent. And yet what has it won us? A Donald Trump presidency
of the second >> They would be they would be they would
be even more successful in convincing kind of normies over to
their side. They would be even more successful if Democrats did
what you're suggesting, which is this like no unilateral disarmament.
We're not going to disavow the violence until they do it first.
>> Five boy. He stopped making fun of my friend. Food shop.
Confucious say men who shopping for food will wake up next day.
Food shop.
Okay. Uh thank you
noodle doodle for the five. Appreciate it. Republicans would
have even more seats in Congress. They and Donald Trump would
have won by an even larger margin. >> But you still haven't
answered my question. You still haven't answered my question.
What What was the 12 like what has the last like 12 years shown
us? Like Joe Biden winning by a thin margin is a loss, not a
victory. That's the bare minimum.
>> This is a silly way of looking at
>> That's a really silly way of looking at >> Win
by a landslide at the time. I don't I wanted Joe Biden to win
by a
the difference between Joe Biden winning and losing >> appreciate
Joe Biden being the >> I would also say Democrats totally
[__] themselves in terms of this election specifically
with Joe Biden sticking in it while his brain was melting. Okay.
In most election years, I don't think Trump really has a shot
at all. But you played in Democrats as a party as a I guess political
operation just totally played into every conspiracy theory of
the right with the whole with the Joe Biden thing. Like you yourselves
completely. Um, which sucks, but I don't know. I don't know what
to tell you, man. >> But we all >> One second here.
I've got a beard. >> The difference between Joe Biden winning
and losing >> appreciate Joe Biden being the president,
but we all expected Joe Biden to crush Donald Trump. The fact
that it was even
was was horrifying. >> You can choose to be sat like listen
like pain is inevitable and suffering is optional in this spot.
Okay? So you can choose to focus on the fact that so many people
in this country trust a corrupt con man. You can stew in that
and you can live in that and you can just be boiling with rage
and depression and sadness if you choose. If you want to do that,
you can do that. Okay? Or you can accept that things are the
way that they are and then try to be pragmatic in how you navigate
the world that you live in. >> What you're doing is not
you are not being pragmatic.
No, I am being proud. Okay. All right. Fine. From your from your
pers, we just disagree on strategy then, right? Because the thing
is that we don't disagree on descriptive reality, right? Well,
like it's like it's like we're talking with each other on how
to conduct our campaigns, right? Like, okay, you have your own
pragmatic strategy. I have my own pragmatic strategy and we're
just disagreeing with each other. We're like two campaign managers
who are disagreeing with one >> Well, I would just really
encourage, you know, I would just really encourage everybody
in both of our chats, you know, we all have like normie people
in our lives. Ask them. Literally ask them. I want you to I want
everybody in my chat to go talk to their normie friends and their
normie co-workers that don't consume political coverage every
day. And I want you to ask them how would you feel if Barack
Obama said I am not going to disavow until Donald Trump disavows
and just listen to what they tell you. I would encourage you
guys to go touch grass, talk to people and ask them how they
would react. >> Punch touch baby. >> Uh actually
I hate Punch's political takes but on a personal level/ mindset
he's cooking here. Dude, all it takes is the most unhinged
going after you and you can easily win. Okay? Right? Like that's
that's all it takes is somebody who has no capability of making
any arguments, who's just like soy signaling the whole time.
And Hutch looks >> Donald Trump disavows and just listen
to what they tell you. I would encourage you guys to go touch
grass, talk to people and ask them how they would >> Touch
touch baby. This is again, if this person had any like social
savvy at all when they did this, it would be way different. But
this is like this is lizard like it's just gross. I have a hypothetical.
Okay, my beloved. Um,
let's just say we have a moderate family. Okay, they call themselves
moderate. Okay, so they voted for Trump three times. Okay, even
though they still call themselves moderate. Um, they don't believe
in MAGA. They hate MAGA or whatever. Do you think like the moderate
in this country who still consider themselves moderate after
12 years would change their vote to Democrat after we disavow
this?
>> That's a really hyper specific example. I mean maybe.
>> Okay, fine. The vast majority of moderates. Vast majority.
>> Maybe we need to we need to we need to define we need
to define moderate. We need to define moderate.
>> We need to define moderate. >> I'm bringing the
same hush. If somebody voted for Trump three times in a row,
they're probably going to vote for If somebody voted for Trump
three times in a row, they're probably going to vote for Trump
again.
>> Just Hutch is losing track of like, okay, all we have
to do He's just comparing his position to your position, right?
What would your position do to somebody who's done that multiple
times in a row? It wouldn't be better. It's just worse in every
situation. It's literally worse in every possible way.
Like you're the the problem isn't like, oh, are you going to
change minds with this position? The pro the issue is like, hey,
I'm going to like not kick myself in the balls after I just got
shot in the shoulder, right? That's you're just trying to minimize
damage right now. >> Okay. How they didn't vote? They didn't
vote um
they didn't vote for one time, but they vote for Trump one time
and Joe Biden for another time. How about that? Like the [__]
>> Yes, disavowing definitely helps with that voter. Yes,
a thousand%. Yes. >> Let's just say Okay, let's just say
the >> Hutch just needs to ask back. Okay, which voter
does not disavowing help you with? Just describe that voter to
me. Which of those voters were voting were not voting Democrat
before and are now coming over because you've not disavowed Charlie
Kirk getting shot in the neck?
Okay. All right. So yes, even though it helps that voter, do
you don't you think that maybe it is a procon like sub minus
like analysis where you're like, okay, yeah, even though we can
win over some moderates, we can't win over enough like to the
point because the time is better spent turning out our base,
right? Does that make sense? >> No, it does not. It we
don't if you >> this is literally like
the people who don't want the violence dish out are like the
tanky people. Like that's the base you're trying to turn out.
You're like you're appealing not even to the Hassan crowd. You're
appealing to like the H crowd right now. That's who you're appealing
to with this. >> Focus on the base. If you focus on the
base in a presidential election, you're you're probably not going
to do well most of the time. The whole point of like advancing
to the general is to uh widen your tent. You need to go beyond
your base. Donald Trump was able to successfully do it, I think,
by appeal like mostly appealing to his base, but he was also
running on like, you know, kind of Okay. >> I have a question.
Hush, cuz I love you. Okay. Um, Husky Hutch. Okay. Cuz I like
your voice. Okay. Um, do you think that Democratic Party has
tried to appeal to moderates this entire time?
What do you So, >> yes. Hutch has >> be more specific.
Are we talking
>> uh the Democratic Party doesn't try to does not try
to appeal to moderates. The Democratic Party is trying to build
like a block like a a statistical
certainty victory in each like federal election. uh national
election, I think you call them, right? The issue with the Democratic
party is they've got this massive tent and if they could turn
out all of their cohorts, they will win like every single election.
But the issue is some some of the some of the like voting blocks
have what would you call it? Like um
their their issues don't overlap with each other as much anymore.
There's a lot of like contention between these voter blocks and
they can't turn out their entire base, right?
But they it's not that they even have to make plays for moderates.
They they do like a bunch of different politics to try to go
Yeah. They they conflict a lot of the time. It's like a totally
different strategy. You can still try to go to the more moderate
people. You can try to appeal, but those individual voter blocks
they had are starting to not like that shift towards moderates.
But trust me, a ton of those voter blocks, everybody just wants
you to disavow violence. None of those voter blocks, none of
this strategy is helped by going, "Yeah, I don't want to disavow
Charlie Kirk getting shot in the neck." You say they can't. Well,
I think a lot of the issues are being split in a way that those
those voter blocks conflict with each other. Um, they'll almost
certainly always win midterms, though. Midterms, that strategy
is really good. Presidential elections is harder >> about
just presidential elections. Are we talking about generally like
what are we talking about here? Cuz you can find uh Democrats
that run on very like like very like in a D plus 50 district
or whatever. Those are going to be people that just like exclusively
focus on the base. in a D plus like two or R plus2 district or
something like that. Those people are going to try to appeal
to a lot of moderates as well. >> Presidential presidential
election go
>> uh yeah like this is what every presidential nominee
basically accept Donald Trump but even he tried to make gestures
to you know kind of get people that are like in the middle by
appealing to sort of like economic populism. Um but every presidential
nominee they run
like came up for oxygen right there. Hold on. >> To sort
of like economic populism.
>> Hold on. Watch. Watch. Watch this >> Oh, [__]
>> Get people that are like in the middle by appealing
to sort of like economic populism. Uh
>> something about that just caught me just like with their
eyes wide open. I don't >> Every presidential nominee they
run uh like the the successful ones like pivoted to the center.
Trump doesn't even Trump doesn't even come close to appealing
to the moderate, but he appeals to them anyway. Why do you think
that is? >> Wait, he does on social issues. Democrats got
really far over their skis on social issues in a lot of different
ways. It was a part of a cultural movement and they have had
a very hard time like rejecting and pulling back to where the
rest of the country was. >> That's just facts, man. >> Is
because people felt like their um they were making more money
and their dollar went further when he was president. I just answered
your question. No, >> no, no. You're wrong. You're You're
>> Wait, hang on. Stop. Pause. You don't. >> It's
a moderate social issue. It's um Democrats not wanting to be
accused of being racist by their base or not racist, but uh bigoted
by their base. And so when they say like, "Oh, yeah, there's
like operations for trans prisoners," they don't come out and
say, "No, that's we don't do that. We don't want policy like
that." They don't say that. They say, "Oh, well, that's not really
necessarily what it was." does. And you see if you actually look
at the the overlapping like the overlapping effect of the this
is just like medical insurance in in prisons or medical coverage
in prisons. >> Go ahead. >> Yeah. Or when they sorted
out because God god forbid someone make a joke about how dirty
Puerto Rico is. >> Sure. Sure. Sure. Uh Camala didn't talk
about trans. That's the thing, Rehox, is people think you can
get away from your history without disavowing it and you can't.
That's the problem, right? They think that you can go and say,
"Oh, well, you know, I haven't talked about that at all." Yeah,
but you did. Why do I Why would I believe Why would I believe
you believe something different than your voting record?
Yes. You Your voting record speaks for itself. I'm like going
on and then you when I ask you about it, you don't like disavow.
You don't say, "Oh, that was wrong." You just say, "No, that
is Yeah. You just like try to change the topic." >> Yeah.
or when you gaslight me into believing that Puerto Rico is a
clean
like beautiful place. >> Anonymous just tipped $5. >> Oh,
hold on. >> The Dems need to stop appealing to food shops
Americans.
People don't want to see food shop Americans
in Ohio.
>> Sorry, we got a donation there. What did you say that
cut over you? Ohio. Oh, >> when they eat the pets in Ohio,
>> don't say the Haitians are eating the cats and the dogs,
[__] They might be. >> Oh yeah, Portortoella
might have uh
you I can't comment on the Haitians. Okay, the Haitians alone.
I just can't comment on it. >> I will comment. They eat
dirt cookies.
>> All right. >> Do we have to go through this again?
>> No, we don't have to go through this again. Uh Porter
Beller says, "Wasn't her voting record was her messaging from
the 2020 primaries?" Sure. Which I mean that can come back to
bite you. The the place culturally the Democrats were gotten
to a weird place where I think they got again I just put it as
like over your skis, right? Like you are you're going down the
hill and you aren't stopping. You're not slowing down. You're
going way too fast. And now Oh [__] If you try to
hit the brakes, you're going to crash. Right. >> Warp thing
says the Haitians might not be eating the cats and the dogs,
but the Chinese are definitely eating the ducks from the park.
>> What's the Alex Jones meme? I don't know. I don't know
if you guys know this, but the ducks at the park are free. You
can just take them. I have 37 ducks at home. It's the Alex Jones
meme. >> Does he have 37?
>> I never heard that. >> I don't think he said it.
I just think it's like a libertarian joke. It's like the the
ducks at the park are free. You just take them home. >> I
remember my aunt ran over a duck in Florida and my Abella made
her pull over so my could take it and cook it at home. >> That
is wild and weird and okay. >> Myella is from Dr. So that
wasn't very
>> What the uh It feels kind of odd, but you know, you
guys got to do you. Jesus. Uh people do that here sometimes,
but I think you can't do it. I think it's like actually illegal
to >> Well, there's like >> I think it was illegal.
>> It was probably illegal where they did it, too. My quick
with it. >> Kind of like what is that? What RFK said he
did? Didn't he like hit a bear or something and so he like he
like had to put the bear in the back of his vehicle and then
he dumped it in Central Park or some [__] >> Is
that where he got brain worms?
>> Maybe. Probably from eating wild meat. Yeah, that's
how you get brain worms. >> Oh, evil Johnny Bravo. There
are not multiple
cherry stories involving a car and dead animals. Calm down. >> Oh,
interesting. You get a salvage tag. Okay. I didn't know that.
Dumped in because his kids and wife were in the car complaining
about the smell. He wanted to bring it home and eat it. The weirdo.
Oh, damn. But he dumped it in Central Park, which is just weird.
>> Yeah. Anyway. Anyway, speaking of weird, >> um,
they were making more money and their dollar went further when
he was president. I just answered your question. No, >> no,
no. You're wrong. You're wrong. >> Wait, hang on. Stop.
Pause. You don't think you're wrong. >> You don't think
that a large chunk of this country voted for Donald Trump because
they felt like their dollar went further during the first term?
Are you seriously suggesting that? >> Wrong. You're wrong.
You're wrong. You're wrong. The reason >> it's Hold on.
It's like stupid to believe that's the reason, but it did. The
the economy was very different. America was far more advantaged
at that point. That's just facts. Economy's changed a lot in
the past like 8 years, but that's just facts, man. white people.
You can't just repeat I'm wrong. I'm wrong. Every sing >> every
single person who had a job, I don't know if food shops didn't
have a job, but if you had a job, you know how far your dollars
went back then. Okay, you do know it's way different. >> Survey
after the election said that people focus first and foremost
on the economy. The economy was the number one issue on every
survey that we saw after the [__] election. >> I
agree. >> It's not just the pandemic twisted rope. There's
a lot of different things that have with the economy. >> That's
why he won. >> I agree. No, >> that's why he won.
>> Number one issue. Okay, >> that is literally why
he won >> was the economy. The number one issue for voters
that >> was the economy. No, no, answer that. >> Okay,
I'm going to match your energy now. Okay, the thing is is that
yes, the number one issue nationally at the time is the economy,
right? Overall, >> Hutch is Hutch in this [__]
place. Okay, Hutch and Cash Patel have share a soul. I don't
know what's going on here. Hutch does this a lot. He's just always
doing it. Like it's you can get like a hundred of these screenshots
any given Hutch stream. All right, eyes pop it >> Why do
you think Trump wins all the time? Why do you think Trump wins?
>> He's edgy. He's He's funny. He's He's a social media
personality. That's why. Right, Hutch? >> The number one
reason why he won something different. >> What is that
movie? What is that movie where they show you this like live
video feed of somebody?
Um
they're like being tortured. the water's like rising above like
over their chin. If you like don't call by this time or if you
do this or that like the person's going to die. Like he's being
blackmailed to continue this debate with food shops and he's
like watching somebody get like gruesomely tortured on his third
monitor or something.
But he has to keep going and if he stops talking it's person
just like keeps getting worse.
>> I don't know but untraceable
>> Yeah. Yeah. >> Okay. Yeah. I've never seen it.
Yeah. Never seen it. You only need to cam up if you keep talking
about appearances. Wait, who's talking about appearances? I'm
saying he's like popping. His eyes are popping out. It's not
saying he's an ugly person. Are you insane? >> I've cammed
up before. Why would I have to cam up for this? >> I don't
know. >> That's why. Right.
>> The number one reason why he won in >> Do you
think the normies really know the ins and outs of the economy
outside of like buying milk at the grocery store?
>> Yeah, exactly. That's what I thought. Hutch. The thing
is only what, like 23% of people are stock owners or something
like that or like 40%. It doesn't even >> It's literally
the groceries. It's literally the groceries. It's literally the
groceries. It's the groceries. It's rent. It's It's the It was
inflation.
>> You understand that people don't know what the economy
is like? They just know what the like their bills are, right?
Yeah. That's what they mean when they say the economy. That's
literally what they mean. That's for the purpose of this argument.
That is exactly what we're all talking about. You sound like
you realize you sound like a MAGA person right now, right? You
you're bringing up inflation to me prior to the um prior to the
election because you want to convince me like that voting Trump
is right. You >> this person is out of their [__]
This person is so bad at
>> I don't know what this person is trying to do. >> No,
this is it is the opposite. It was Democrats who tried to say
look how good like the housing market is like the economy is
going to be okay, right? And then it was Trump who's like, "No,
the price of eggs is crazy." Do you see how expensive bacon is?
They don't even put bacon on anything anymore.
>> right. Or am I confused? >> Well, she's making
something like that argument. She's making basically the argument
that like only Trump supporters care about the economy. Everyone
cares about the economy. So, but but she's saying that you're
trying to convince people to vote Trump because you're saying
the economy is bad. The economy was bad. I don't know. I'm sorry,
man. I just don't get how anybody argues the economy is not worse
when I know I know what people's raises are like and I know what
the price difference is for like everyday goods.
Like so many things are like 50 to 80% more expensive and nobody's
gotten that level of raise. You had to be making your money to
not feel that like substantially. I don't know how people who
make like >> I don't know how how people who make like
$50,000 a year live to be honest with you. I just I have no idea.
called like kitchen table issues, right?
>> Like this is more influential than the housing market
for a lot of Americans.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. That's why gas prices are such
a big deal for people. If you want to cry, watch the Home Alone
shopping scene where he gets two bags of groceries for 20 bucks.
Damn. People I work with have four roommates and makes 75K a
year barely making it. I don't know about that, but I do I do
know it's like, dude, it's so expensive right now. Crazy out
there. Is like nuts. >> Yeah, dude. Do you go to the movie
theaters and they're like if you want a large popcorn that's
going to be $15?
What the >> Yeah, fill of gas. What the [__]
are you talking about? Oh, I'm not saying gas is bad right now,
Ronox. I'm saying that gas is the thing that used to be the big
economic indicator, right? Gas is is a thing. If gas prices go
up, that hits people politically so hard. It's why you used to
see all those Joe Biden stickers, the I did it stickers when
gas prices were spiking when the Russia thing happened right
away. Right. Yeah. I'm just pointing out that that's obviously
like one of those kitchen table things. Gas is $4 is not great.
I don't even know, dude. But anyway, I think I think people who
think it's just a vibe session, I think people just don't get
it. Vibe session is like a thing I see from people who are really
detached or really economically insulated most of the time. But
I don't >> Realize that's you're playing into their book.
You don't even realize that you >> What are you talking
about? What are you talking about? I am telling you what every
opinion is survey after the election they all said the same thing
statistically okay that's just great okay yeah I agree with you
statistically >> why did incumbent parties all over the
issue why were
why were incumbent parties all over the >> why were incumbent
parties all over the world so um like battered in like in the
postco uh like elections it's because the whole world experienced
>> the whole world experienced global inflationary pressures.
>> Oh, not sorry, not the beans. >> People People
It felt like their money wasn't going as far as it was. People
were squeezed. >> People had to The Republicans Hutch,
>> what are you? >> The Republicans were lying. What
are you talking about? They >> They were lying about inflation.
>> The the entire But they blamed the Democrats. Hush.
They blamed the >> Dude, this is like >> That is
correct. It was I think I think a lot of the inflation could
be linked to Trump's tax the the tax thing that he pushed in
what was it? >> Well, I mean there's lots of there Republicans
didn't do anything to help it and Republicans I'd say it's more
about um like the inflationary pressures of the economy. He should
have as president been trying to slow the economy down the whole
time. Like people were spending way too much. People were borrowing
and um and people were borrowing tax cuts and you give tax cuts
to people. It was like insane. >> Yeah. Yeah. You give
tax cuts to people too. So it's just um I don't know man. It's
uh sorry. Johnny Bravo evil Johnny Bravo also talked about price
over earnings. Apparently that scale is not great. It's the stimulus
after the CO dip without the Fed raising rates. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
In terms of Yes. Money was free. Yes. Sorry. I'm also I'm trying
to click through some of these but it's like dude the >> Yep.
crazy. >> The economy is like uh it's you can't say don't
talk about the economy being bad because Republicans blame it
on us. You can't say that. You have to talk about the economy.
You have to address the economy no matter what. You can't just
not dress it. You can't just go well uh what are you going to
do? The the economy is a Republican scop. What other option do
you have? You have to talk about it. >> That's not who
that's not the point. Who cares? Of course. Yeah, of course they
>> the entire point. Yes, the blame is the entire point.
If it's just inflation, if it's just simply inflation, then sure.
But the thing is is that it's inflation during um uh uh like
like why blaming it on the Democrats? That makes things entirely
different. >> We're talking about two separate things right
now. >> An inherent issue into a blaming thing. >> We
were talking about two separate things right now. Right or wrong?
It doesn't. No. Right or wrong. Right or wrong? People blamed
Biden. >> Yes or no? Yeah. Yes or no? Yeah. Yes or no?
Me? Yeah. Go ahead. Yeah. Okay. Please go. Yeah. What's up? Please
go. >> I didn't say I didn't say yes or no. It said right
or wrong. People blamed >> Right or wrong. Okay.
>> No, I'm not asking you.
>> Oh, this person's brain is so broken. What the [__]
>> That's not even pisco
>> for Well, he's saying for better or worse, people blame
Biden. Like, correct or incorrect, they they blame Biden. Whether
or not it was the right thing to do, they blame Biden. And she's
like, "Oh, yeah. You trying to be piss right?"
This person's brain is broken. You a question. I'm saying okay
to you, Hutch. How is that okay to you? Like, right or wrong,
people are blaming Biden. It's not okay. How is that okay? He's
obviously He's obviously on the wrong side. Hutch is obviously
saying
that is wrong. He thinks it's wrong.
When TG sends their people, they're not sending their best. No,
this is their best. This is their best. >> What are you
talking about? >> I'm a I'm a bit confused about your reaction
right now. I am not I am not >> frame Biden for inflation,
right? >> I agree. That's not the point I'm making. I'm
not saying like, hey, this was Biden.
>> You can literally see Lutnik and Bessant flailing on
the news to try and deflect how the economy is and will be. They
know it's coming. Dude, Bessant just keeps like hitting people
in the face. I've heard Bessant just treats the White House as
his own personal fight club. You walk around the White House,
he just throws haymakers at people out of nowhere. This Bessant
guy's unhinged.
>> My point was that political leaders all over the world
experienced catastrophic political losses when the world economy
contracted after co and people felt the sting of inflation. Voters
all over the world because most people are politically disengaged
blamed the incumbent parties and that was the number one reason
why Donald Trump won in 2024. It was not because he was running
like aggressively targeting his base. You're just wrong about
that. >> Okay. What does that have to do with the Democrats?
Uh, wait, this was 2024, right? You're talking about 2024. I
am getting my time mixed up. I never go >> We lost in 2024.
Yeah. >> Okay. Yeah. And what could we have done >> I
like this is what happens when you know you have a position and
you're going to argue that position no matter what, regardless
of any actual knowledge you have. It's probably in general like
actually quite harmful to yourself, your like brain, um to your
audience, to everybody if you platform people like this who do
not care about the actual issues. They don't bother to get informed.
They just know they can pick a team and then they can argue them
and they're going to come and argue them as if they have some
position like this. You're never going to change their mind.
Something completely outside of reality has dictated their position
to them and nothing you could say will change their mind. Like
that's the argument that Hutch is engaged in. >> Okay,
but what do you do when this is exactly what Hutch wanted, right?
You're part of the team. You're part blue no matter who. >> To
be fair, Hutch might just want this now because it's like, thank
god I can I can beat somebody.
Thank god I can win one. I got one.
>> Are you saying he like I don't know intentionally made
it so that he's playing baseball or softball with a bunch of
women? >> Maybe. Is he actually I'm getting very close
to a trans joke so I'm gonna stop >> Okay. All right. All
right. >> I don't know that I mean that listen that would
have been that was that was a tough election man. I mean there's
there's ways that that Kamla could have done a better job in
terms of like we I've talked about that a lot. Like her her media
strategy was she was sort of limited as a candidate because she
wasn't very good in long form setting. You know parts of her
campaign I thought were really good and exciting and other parts
just not so much. She was a pretty flawed candidate and so you
know I blame Biden more than her. But we're kind of getting off
the track here. The point the point that I've been trying to
make to you and I want to reiterate to you once again and everybody
in my chat and in your chat if you guys have normies if you guys
have normies in your life >> stream right now you're fine.
Yeah I'm >> okay everybody in my chat then if you guys
have normies in your life ask them like hey what would you think
of the strategy of all Democrats just refusing to disavow and
I promise you I promise you that the vast majority of normies
in your life are going to say that would be unhinged. I would
not like that. >> Yeah, it would be unhinged, but in the
long run, we would still lose. Hutch, >> then what's the
>> What? I know it would be unhinged and we'll lose in
the short in the short run, but in a long one run, we will also
lose. Hutch,
I I just Yeah. Yeah. That's who we're That's who we're listening
to right now. >> In your life are going to say that would
be unhinged. I would not like that. We watch it again. >> Yeah,
it would be unhinged, but in the long run, we would still lose.
Hutch, >> then what's the All right, so now you're black
build. We're going to lose no matter what. What's the point?
>> No, if we continue with your strategy, we will lose.
>> No, your >> So, she just didn't listen to what
he was saying. Okay. >> Strategy is guaranteed to lose
voters.
>> We have to attack the Republican party. >> And
we should. So >> and we should and we and we and we >> but
we shouldn't. >> What they Nobody just addresses this question.
Why can you not say I disavow violence and attack the Republican
party? I that's this is it's so easy. It's it's not difficult.
>> We shouldn't we shouldn't condition
>> we shouldn't condition discipline in front of Republicans
on a panel. It's not a concession. Like it depends in a pan in
a in a panel in a panel. Wait, hold on. In a in a panel setting,
I think you can do your strategy and make it work. Okay. But
I'm talking about like broadly people out there in the media
and certainly like elected Democrats or Democratic leaders in
the party. Okay. If you're on a Piers Morgan panel, that's one
thing. Okay. I can I I can maybe I can maybe wake make my way
to like your position of like, yeah, maybe maybe you shouldn't,
you know, quote unquote unilaterally disarm in that kind of a
setting. But when we're talking about political leaders, we're
talking about like uh >> I still don't think that's I I
still think you are doing harm if you do the panel thing. I just
it's such a stupid distinction to make. >> Are Yeah, I
It's so It's so dumb. I
maybe if you're like maybe if you're like you know on a panel
you could just lie and and say or
>> liberal voices that are elevated media they definitely
need to be out there in a unified front condemning political
violence in a moment like this otherwise that will damage the
Democratic party politically. That's what I'm trying to get you
to see. I'm trying to appeal to your stated goal of pragmatism
by telling you I promise you that it's going to lose Democrats
voters if every Democrat in the country did what you're >> Okay.
So, my answer is this. Okay. I agree that you should again um
I'm pretty sure I said this before. You should disavow assassinations.
You should disavow vigilanteism on your own time, on your own
stream. You should make that clear. You should blow that up.
However, at the same time, in the same breath, at the same time
of disavowing the violence, you shouldn't just turn against the
left and criticize the left for blowing up like violence. I didn't
say that, which I'm sure you agree with. Yeah. Which is said
you agree with. Yes, I know. I know. I know. I'm not ascribing
that position to you. Okay. But I'm saying at the same time as
disavowing the violence, disavowing the assassination, don't
you think that it's also good to point out that hey, Donald Trump's
rhetoric is not helping? Donald Trump's like insane is not helping.
>> Oh, okay. So, wait. So, where do we disagree? What the
>> You said >> a Hutch believer. He might be kind
of a dummy, but I truly think he can work his way around to the
right position. >> Uh, hold on. Hutch doesn't like I think
Hutch is like fine as a person a lot of the time. But a lot of
the time, but the issue is he will also start for he he's done
the same thing food shops has done here. I think Hutch is like
a obviously like a better person in general. He does like more
work than Food Chops. But we watched with the chorus thing. He
came out right out of the gate with like not understanding what
was going on and and saying things and amplifying things that
were just false because that appealed to like his political inclination.
I don't I don't hate Hutch, but like he's
I don't I'm not going to like go and say he's like awesome because
of this. >> Don't do it until they do it. That's what you
said. You said don't disavow until they do it. >> Yeah.
That's generally like in general. >> No. That's stupid.
>> You shouldn't say too much.
Okay. Yeah. Yeah. But if you say it too much, you're feeding
into them, right?
>> Like if you like like for example, if every single stream
you come on and then you talk about this issue like um as if
like every single stream is going to be an apology stream for
the Democrats, like I I just don't see that working pragmatically.
Does that make sense? >> I I I don't plan on dedicating
streams apologizing on behalf of Democrats. That's not my playbook.
I haven't been doing that. I don't intend on doing that. I think
that would be bad.
>> Well, hey, what if you like what if you actually just
disavowed the violence every time you start a stream forever?
Wouldn't that be bad? Wait, okay, you know, this is the part
where you're like, well, I kind of just want you to leave and
not feel like you threw in every possible way, but so yeah, I
guess so. I guess that would be bad. That totally contrived situation
that would never happen. That that could be bad. >> Sure.
But the thing is is that right now there are absolutely like
it's absolutely the case where um you see all these Republicans
who are right now calling for blood, right? Um and then you are
on your stream. >> Talk about that. >> Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. That's what I'm saying. That's that's my entire point.
>> If you go to my Twitter account, like tell just tell
me what you see for like the last like 3 4 days. It's literally
nothing but calling out to this >> Okay. I haven't looked
at your >> Yeah, that's good. That's fine. >> It's
like [__] I was way too online in the last few days
and it's been a
pushing back against this ridiculous idea that um Democrats are
mostly to blame for political violence. That's all I've been
doing to a degenerate level for like the last like 4 days. >> And
you can totally do that. >> That's so funny. He tells people
who disagrees with him on Twitter that they are mentally ill
and need to log off and touch grass. And then he goes like, "I've
been online non-stop for four days on Twitter doing this."
>> He does tweet a lot. He tweets a lot. He streams a lot.
He tweets a lot. Okay. This guy's all over the place. >> To
my own mental health detriment. Like it's been it's been making
it's been making me crazy.
>> Okay. If that's your position, you realize nobody
>> like disagrees with you, right? >> Pivotal for
Hutch right now. Yeah,
if only there was a tweet saying that. Is there a tweet? Somebody
have like a tweet saying that right now?
>> No, I deleted it as soon as I tweeted it cuz I wanted
to see the mention and then see that the tweet was gone and maybe
think that he was like losing it.
>> Okay, that's a weird side out to pull, >> like
on that >> uh I I don't know if that's ever been an issue
of contention where we disagree is this whole like never disavow
until they disavow. That's bad and stupid and people should definitely
not do that. It's really bad and it will turn off normies. It
will make us look bad. It will damage us politically and it's
just bad for the country. Increases the risk of of violence and
I think like the >> Why do you think people are saying
that? Like why why do you think people are saying that? >> Why
do you think people are saying what? >> Because because
the Democrats are being framed, right?
>> Um how will Desi react to this? I didn't see Desty's
like uh original political take on this. I saw him say don't
disavow until they do or don't dismant until they lower the temperature
or some but I haven't seen I'm guessing he probably realized
that he was a total re he was out on an island by himself. So
I'm guessing later he changed his position and is going to go
actually I changed my position on this if I had to guess. Right.
>> Why do you think people are saying what can you be more
specific? What do you >> disavow? I don't know. >> Okay.
Why do you think people are saying that you shouldn't disavow
until the other side disavows? >> Because they're angry
and they're throwing a tantrum. So, for the record, I think that
they should disavow, but the thing is >> you would be wrong.
Well, I haven't watched it, Rhox. Did he keep the same thing?
He's like stood on on business on that. That seems so stupid
to me, but yeah, maybe. I do. I do like that I made the connection
to the Hassan tactic, though. It is just just the Hassan tactic.
It's very funny >> is that it's perfectly understandable
why they aren't. >> I understand the anger. I really do.
I really do. >> I understand the anger. I have the same
>> I understand my anger. I understand their anger. Okay.
But the reality, Hajj, is this. The Democrats are currently being
framed for the murder of Charlie Kirk. Okay. There are detectives
and police asking you questions and
>> No, I think they got the suspect.
>> Uh, I think they got him right away. Yeah. The Democrats
are currently being framed for the murder of Charlie Kirk. >> I
don't know if this guy was like uh this guy liked trans people.
It doesn't mean he was a Democrat. Although he he could have
been demleaning. I
why let
I don't know why that would matter. I don't know why that lets
you like change your principles entirely.
>> I wouldn't I think everyone would just
>> like guns don't kill people people kill people right
or do we not say that
>> I have no idea about saying that. I'm I'm like I'm saying
that if he's a leftist Oh no. Also Democrats don't say that generally.
They won't say that. But even if he was a leftist, like you still
follow your principles. Like his beliefs don't dictate how you
respond to political violence, right? They shouldn't. They shouldn't
at all. You can't go, "Well, they're trying to say that he was
a leftist, so actually we have to lie and say the political violence
is fine. >> We have to we have to make sure they're scared
of more violence. We can't disavow the violence."
>> I don't know. There are detectives and police asking
you questions and trying to get you to confess your guilt by
saying that you disavow. by saying like in front of them in front
of you disavowed they interpret that >> oh hold on is this
oh never mind >> if I am confronted with listen if I am
confronted with like a real life like a like not necessarily
real life but like if I have an exchange with if I'm on a panel
with someone or if I'm having a conversation with someone and
I'm and then some MAGA person comes at me and says you need to
disaval I'm going to tell that person to [__] off
just to be clear. Oh, bass. Okay. Yeah. No, I told >> I'm
gonna tell that person to off and be like, "Go yourself." That's
essentially like been my That's That's
essentially what I've been doing on Twitter for like the last
like 4 days. I've just been no lifing
nine hours a day just spending way too much on time on Twitter.
>> Okay. However, I'm just asking >> there is there
is very real value in in as many people in the country as possible
saying unequivocally that political violence is never acceptable.
There is value to that. It's not it is a reinforcement of a very
important liberal principle. >> Sure. I I agree that's
fine. Okay. Like obviously it would be insane if anyone was like
pro. >> You should watch the Wick panel. I'm curious what
your thoughts are on the whole thing. Is this uh what's your
thoughts on the whole thing is especially considering how funny
this spur is probably butchering it. Um maybe I might let it
marinate for just a little bit here cuz I Excuse me. I've got
some other stuff I wanted to do as well. Um I really got to get
to the action man thing after this. Okay. That's that's big bucks.
That's big money right there. Okay. Whatever's going on there,
I got to see it. What >> I'm I'm going to hedge my Did
it call hedge my bets? >> Yeah. I I feel like Action Man
around and that maybe Lauren's not completely in the wrong >> possibly.
What happened with Action Man? Action Man kicked Lauren de Laguna
out of his house. Riyle, how do you not know about this? How
do you not know about this? I got to figure out what's going
on there. >> [__] boy to intentionally try
to [__] over a girl so he has content. >> Yeah,
sure. Yeah, I think so. But I don't know. This is lunatic. Lauren
showed up at at the action house today for no reason. Refused
to leave, so I called the police as always. She actually walked
in the house also. Proud snitch, proud cop caller. Cannot wait
to move out of this place. Is like the first tweet. >> Lunatic
Lauren. >> I Yeah, it's crazy, man. I got to we got to
get to that. Okay, so let's finish this debate and then I'm going
to do that and then maybe we'll do maybe we'll do panel. We'll
see. We'll see what >> assassination, right? Obviously,
but like I said, Hutch, I don't disagree on this. You realize
that, right? like we've been over the same point over and over
again. Like we don't disagree on >> I agree that we don't
disagree on that. Where we disagree is the unilateral disarmament.
That's a silly principle. Stop doing it. Don't do it. It's bad.
It's going to hurt us. >> Unilateral? What do you mean
by unilateral disarmament? >> Okay,
I've I'll run out of my patience. You know what it means. Come
on. What are you doing? Why are you asking me that question?
You know the answer to that question. Don't ask Don't ask me
a rhetorical question. If you if you mean by that Okay. If you
mean by that that um we shouldn't disavow until they do as a
whole for the Democrats side. Yeah, I >> Okay.
I'm glad I've pulled you over to my side. >> No, no, no,
no, no. I I mean I mean I mean I agree with the fact that they
shouldn't disavow until they do. >> No, no, no. I'm not
sold. I'm not sold.
>> No, no, no. I meant actually I position at all. >> He
just Hutch just said he's going to swear to God. >> It's
not We need you. We my collision. >> No, you know what?
I'm sad again. It was good talking to you. I got to go. I got
to get some food in me. Uh we'll we'll >> That's the problem
is Hutch. Okay. They don't have a reasoned position. You can't
do anything. There's nothing in another time. It's already over
to kill >> Okay. In a video game. In a video game. In a
video game. In a video game. In a video game. >> Wow. Wow.
Wow.